President Trump is in Paris this morning
for two days of Kemmer commemorations
around the 100th anniversary of the end
of World War one mr. Trump says he wants
a strong Europe and that the Allies must
be fair in sharing the cost of that
defense French president Manuel McCraw
agreed but there is controversy we saw
Jang is traveling with the president we
took good morning oh good morning
Anthony that conversation will continue
throughout the weekend but right now
President Trump and the first lady are
having a social luncheon with their
French counterparts they just announced
though they will not be visiting an
American Cemetery as planned due to this
rainy and windy weather meanwhile the
president is dealing with a domestic
controversy brewing over the new leader
of the Department of Justice even though
mr. Trump is thousands of miles away
here in Paris military and president
Trump kicked off his second official
visit to France with a meeting with
President Emmanuel macron the two
outlined common interests and exchanged
warm words and we have become very good
friends over the last couple of years
and we have much in common in many ways
but the president used a different tone
toward McCrone minutes before landing in
Paris while still aboard Air Force one
he tweeted president McCrone of France
has just suggested that Europe build its
own military in order to protect itself
from the US China and Russia very
insulting but perhaps Europe should
first pay its fair share of NATO which
the u.s. subsidizes greatly mr. Trump
has long criticised European countries
for not contributing enough to NATO
they have also clashed on immigration
issues before leaving the White House
the president issued a proclamation
denying asylum to migrants who enter the
US illegally which was immediately
challenged in court
we're not letting ax men
but they're trying to flood our country
President Trump also tried to put
distance between him and the acting
Attorney General Matt Whitaker worked
for Jeff Sessions and he was always
extremely highly thought of that he
still is but I didn't know Matt Whitaker
a contradiction from what he said last
month on Fox News but I can tell you
Matt Whitaker is a great guy I mean I
know Matt Whitaker but I never talked
about conversations that I had Whitaker
will now oversee Special Counsel Robert
Mueller's investigation into Russian
meddling in the 2016 election Democrats
are calling for Whitaker to recuse
himself because he has publicly
criticized the probe before I think that
you know fundamentally you know this
investigation by Bob Mahler needs to be
limited and in an interview to air this
Sunday on Face the Nation House
Democratic Leader Nancy Pelosi said she
thinks Whitaker needs to step aside I
think that he should recuse himself for
any review of the investigation because
the statements he has made already in
the public domain
when asked if Whitaker was picked to
rein in the investigation the president
said this what a stupid question that is
what a stupid question a president Trump
tried to clarify his relationship with
Whitaker and a couple of really early
tweets saying that he knew Whitaker as
the chief of staff to former attorney
General Jeff Sessions but not socially
and in a letter obtained by CBS News
from Whitaker to the DOJ staff he said
he is committed to leading a fair
department Dana also the president
tweeting about the Forest Service
earlier this morning we judge Aang in
Paris Thank You EJ